we are having our very first talk which
is going to be a new series that we're
implementing from the careers team where
we are speaking to experts in an
industry and today we are going to be
talking specifically about self-driving
cars and the autonomous systems industry
so really exciting we get a lot of
questions and interest from students
around this topic so we're excited to
start our very first one on this topic
and give you all some insights into the
industry as well as hear from our expert
so if you have not seen me before my
name is Brett Ellis I am a career coach
here with Udacity I work with students
primarily on helping them with their job
search process personal branding
different things around those topics my
background is in higher education and
made that transition to career coaching
in general and working with
professionals I'm glad back in the place
working with students and I love doing
these types of interactive workshops so
if you do have any questions regarding
the actual job search process or want
help post viewing this session
feel free to schedule a coaching call
with myself or any of our other career
coaches on staff and we are joined today
by vienna harvey if you want to go ahead
Vienna I'll let you take it away you're
gonna give a much better intro for
yourself than I will sure thanks for
having me Brett and great to be here so
as you can see here my name is Deanna
Harvey and I am a tech coach here at
Udacity in our school of autonomous
systems so what that means is that I
work with mentors and students who are
taking our autonomous systems nano
degree programs and I also manage our
self-driving cars that we have at the
office here her name is Carla and for
anyone who's taken our self-driving car
engineering Ana degree program and done
the capstone project of that program
Carla is the car that we use to test
actual student code on which i think is
pretty cool that students get to see the
code run on an actual car as part of
that nano degree very cool
so today I want to run through the
agenda a little bit and really set some
expectations for this session
considering the fact that this is the
news we want to make sure that standing
what well as what it isn't designed for
so the first thing we want to make sure
that students are aware of is this is
not a session to ask questions
specifically about your nano degree
program or about your project this is
gonna be more so focused on higher level
topics as it relates to the industry as
well as hearing from Vienna specifically
about her individual career path and how
she kind of found her way into this
industry and what she thinks of the
future of the industry so we'll hear
your about some hot topics as well as
industry trends will ask that be in the
shares with us a little bit of a
technical side of some some career
advice because as you might have found
out a lot of our career coaches are
really experts on the job search process
and human resources and we're not coders
we're not programmers we're not
developers or data scientists so it's
great for us to have guests who aren't
experts in those industry because though
those people can oftentimes provide
perspectives that we can't and then we
will open it up at the very end for some
Q&A to answer any questions you might
have either about some of the things
that we're shared or maybe some things
that you weren't able to gain from the
session and then we'll close out and
share with you some other resources
pending that but other than that I'm
gonna stop the screen share and it's
gonna be very conversational between me
and Vienna and so if you would like to
Deana I want you to just kind of share
with the group and the students who may
be watching this replay a little bit
about how are you from the very
beginning I want to know kind of what
sparked your interest in this industry
how you kind of decided this was a path
for you talk a little bit about the
steps you took to get there and if we
have time maybe talk about like your big
next goals sure so my interest in
self-driving cars started in my junior
year at Stanford when I was taking a
class called ethical issues in
engineering and for my final
object for that class I chose as my
topic self-driving cars and I did my
project on ethics and self-driving cars
I thought that was really cool and so
the following year my senior year I took
that same project and expanded it over
the course of an entire year into an
honors thesis about ethics and the
design of self-driving cars and how we
can design ethical self-driving cars
that was what initially sparked my
interest in the field and at the time I
had a family friend who worked at
Udacity who had read my thesis and
showed it to David silver who leads our
self-driving car program here and she
ended up introducing me to David and so
then several months later when I was
looking for a job I reached back out to
Udacity and was hired here to work on
our self driving car programs and have
since expanded that to managing several
of our nano degree programs within the
school of autonomous systems but I do
still manage our self-driving car as
well as you may have guessed from the
topic of my thesis something I am really
interested in is sort of the ethics
design legal side of self-driving cars
as opposed to specifically focusing on
just the technical side so I think it's
really exciting to see some of the
recent developments that are emerging in
the self-driving car industry and how
things like design and regulation are
starting to come into play a little more
very cool I think you mentioned
something that's very important for us
to acknowledge and something that we
have conversations with students a lot
about is that you know whether it was
your college degree or whether it's a
student's nano degree oftentimes that's
not enough in order to secure someone a
job so you mentioned like the
connections that you were able to hold
on as a way to kind of work your way
into the industry and so I'm really glad
that you mentioned that point because a
lot of students they really kind of
focused solely on going in in applying
for jobs online and that's really their
only strength so I'm glad that you
touched on that and
I want to encourage other students like
regardless of the nanodegree program
that you're interested making sure that
part of your strategy also includes
network for the industry that you're
trying to get into so along kind of it's
talking about like what you're really
interested in what is kind of going on
in the industry
what do you see as some of the things
that people should be aware of if
they're considering going into this
industry so maybe untapped areas that
have high potential for career growth or
maybe just things that a lot of people
in the industry are talking about what
about the hot topics and the trends that
are that you're seeing within the
self-driving car on autonomous systems
industry as far as jobs go I would say
something to be aware of is that a lot
of the actual jobs out there may be more
specialized than you would initially
think for example our nano degree
program is called self-driving car
engineer but that's really just a broad
overview and if you are to actually go
into a job at a company that's working
on self-driving cars it's quite likely
that you'll end up in a role that's
called perception engineer or sensor
fusion engineer or something that's more
specialized so if you have an area of
particular interest that you know you
really want to go deep in that area I'd
say that's great do that and really
pursue becoming an expert in that more
specific area if that's something that
you're interested in or you can go the
other route and start out by
establishing yourself as a very well
rounded generalist and be good at a lot
of different things and figure out maybe
later where you want to go in as a
specialty as far as the companies that
are out there a lot of what we're seeing
right now is companies that are trying
to find similar to the jobs companies
are themselves finding specific little
niches that they want to go into for
example voyage which was founded by
people who came from Udacity originally
they are working on self-driving cars
for a retirement community and so it's a
very specific area
it's very limited scope and so that's
let them really become a front-runner in
their specific area and that's something
that I think we're seeing is with a lot
of companies is their rather than trying
to cover the entire board at once
they're just picking a specific area of
focus to begin on okay
great and so let's say for example
somebody is interested in kind of this
industry not necessarily going to
self-driving car route are there any
other options that you think kind of the
the education and the skills that
they're learning in the nanodegree might
prepare them for absolutely so we have a
lot of exciting developments with drones
recently I'm sure people has heard a lot
about that maybe you've heard about the
Amazon delivery drones there is a
company I like a lot called sale drone
that has autonomous little ocean drones
to take ocean health measurements
essentially so that's kind of a
completely different path from
self-driving car but still within the
world of autonomous systems and then
more generally the field of robotics
which is another of our autonomous
systems programs that's a very exciting
field there's always new developments
coming out of that so I think even if
self-driving car is not necessarily your
thing if you're interested in autonomous
systems more generally there's
definitely something for you out there
awesome that I think that'll be really
helpful for a lot of people okay so now
I wanted to kind of shift over to like
specific a lot of students and coaching
veterans they are pursuing this can
degree they're learning this specific
topic but a lot of them at least from my
understanding is like an industry where
you jump in entry level into a
self-driving car engineer type role so
obviously you can see I'm not the
technical expert but what are some what
are some initial steps because I think
that's where students struggle most is
that first step in terms of I am about
to finish my Nana to program where I
just finished my name to be program
looking for ways to gain experience what
is your best advice for somebody in
there like very first day is something
that I've heard a lot from companies
that we have worked with as I've talked
with them is that they can teach you the
specifics of their company or their role
but they can't necessarily teach you to
be a good software engineer and so even
if you're interested in self-driving
cars or drones say if you can get good
hands-on experience more generally as a
software engineer that will probably
help you in the long run and so even if
you're struggling to get into the
specific industry niche or the specific
company that you're looking at I would
recommend expanding your horizons a
little bit and it's okay to take a first
job that's not exactly what you want to
be doing or exactly where you want to be
if you think about how you can use that
as a stepping stone into a later role ok
engineering that's pretty broad right
aren't there there any specific things
that you would recommend like that they
do so maybe one of the things that you
know I've shared with some students is
you know maybe find a software
engineering job at a automotive company
or somewhere where you're going to be
doing some sort of related work so as it
relates to that like if they are getting
their start and software engineering you
have any kind of like unique tips that
you would provide or specific direction
that you think they should go in I think
that's a really good point about doing
related work or being in a related
position so I would definitely agree
with that
that even even if it's not quite what
you want if you can find something
that's maybe still a company you're
interested in or maybe a similar role to
what you want but at a company that you
don't see yourself in long term and just
kind of trying to find those related
things that can help you incrementally
get closer to where you want to be ok
and then Greg mentioned earlier
networking as well so that's obviously
very important as well just as you're
doing this continue to meet people reach
out to people and form those connections
that can help you get to where you want
to be so yeah you actually like read my
mind a little bit so I talked about the
importance of networking all the time
and
like the the hiring system in general I
feel is kind of broken in terms of like
most companies are pointed pointing
people in the direction of their online
systems but most people are not
necessarily getting hired that way and
so I push networking very heavily so
maybe you can shed some light on some
great networking opportunities for
people within this specific industry
yeah so I think I can't overstate the
importance of networking before I say
anything else I'd like to also just
point out that a lot of people get kind
of freaked out by the term networking
and they think it means just like
choosing with people and not being
genuine and throwing your resume around
everywhere and it doesn't have to be
that any conversation that you have with
anyone else you encountered that can be
networking and I think if you approach
it with that mindset that networking is
more just a side effect of the
interactions that you have as you go
about your life that can help make it
seem less intimidating now within
autonomous systems there are a lot of
really great resources and events that
go on so I I mean just LinkedIn can be a
really great resource if you find groups
that you want to join or topics that
you're interested in following so that
can then start to show you who that
people are who are involved in these
areas and I've had pretty great success
just messaging people humm LinkedIn and
saying hey I'm really interested in your
work can we connect so I can follow you
and people like to talk about what they
do they like to talk about what they're
interested in so if you reach out to
someone expressing interest in what they
do you'll probably get a pretty positive
reception from a good number of people
with that and I found that to be a
really useful tool to find and build
connections within this industry it's
not being afraid to reach out to people
and say hey I like what you do and I
want to see more yeah and I think it's
interesting that you bring up LinkedIn
because whenever I talk to students I'm
like that's my area of expertise and
mostly just because that's where I found
the most about in my own personal career
and I think yeah you bring up a really
good point about that outreach and so I
get a lot of questions about
you know how should I reach out and
where I'm seeing most of the issues is
that's not necessarily you'd ask these
students but most of the people that I
talk to they're finding a job first and
then they're reaching out to try to
connect with job and so I encourage them
to like put yourself in that person's
shoes right it's like you almost it's
almost kind of like you're using me in
order to get this job so you brought up
a really good point about like not to
get a job the point is to connect points
to build relationships the point is to
learn and that's why a lot of this
career stuff needs to be done
proactively instead of waiting for a job
opening and then reaching out because in
that interaction becomes very
transactional exactly and it's not as in
front of that relationship building
because obviously you know if you're
having those conversations with people
and that you maybe contribute to their
content on LinkedIn you leave comments
on their posts like that's how you start
to develop that relationship and then
maybe several months down the road then
you reach out and say hey I saw an
opportunity at your company can you kind
of plug me in or connect but I think
people are so they get in that reactive
mindset like I need to see a job then I
need to apply that I need to reach out
to somebody in that just not the best
way of going about doing it and so I
really like the point that you brought
up as it relates to just trying to
connect with people in learning more
about their experience and having a
genuine interest of connecting with oh
you brought up a really good point about
the networking like networking is not
just you go into an event that is
labeled networking event and going
around and talking to a bunch of
strangers like you said like these types
of conversations happen in your everyday
life and at workshops at conferences at
meetups one-on-one situations and so I
really like the fact that you you're
saying a lot of things that are in
alignment with what we teach especially
from the careers perspective and I think
you're a really good example of what
happens when you follow that path versus
kind of the the quick results path that
just doesn't really tend to work too
well for people yeah if I could jump in
again I would just add on to that to say
I think this is especially important for
an industry like
autonomous systems that's still kind of
an emerging industry that's finding its
footing and so it can be really easy to
feel like everybody in this industry
already knows each other and that all of
the jobs and resources and information
is just kind of staying within that very
closed system and just sending your
resume in on job applications is easy
and quick but probably not the best way
to break into that system but connecting
with people and building those
relationships that can really be your
foot in the door okay so I wanna I want
to open it up to some questions but I
have one last kind of question I want
from you so I was a student and I just
finished me like you're your top piece
of advice like whether it's relates to
like the industry maybe like give me
like your your top ideal campus so that
does depend a lot on the nanodegree
program that you've completed someone
coming out of intro to self-driving cars
is gonna look a lot different as a
candidate than someone coming out of
sensor fusion but in general and
something that I think Udacity does do
well is that it's really great to have
actual projects that you can show and
have those concrete examples of these
are not just the skills I learned but
how I actually applied those skills
that's something that employers really
look for because it shows that you don't
just have a theoretical understanding
you actually have that hands-on
experience so I would say get your
portfolio of your nano degree program
projects ready to go as something that
you can show off to employers and while
you're job searching find a side project
that you can work on and continue to
hone your skills in a very applied
setting okay great and so our employers
taking close looks at some do some don't
but probably best to prepare for the
ones that do so that you won't be caught
unawares okay so definitely have at
least somewhere where you're showcasing
yeah yeah so have somewhere doesn't
particularly matter where
somewhere that employers can go to see
examples of what you've done okay thank
you for all of that so now I'm for those
of you who are joining us we're gonna
open it up for questions so if you want
to feel free to unmute yourself feel
free to turn on the camera or feel free
to type in the chat box and I'll read
the question aloud but now's your chance
while most the time in talking to us
career experts we're not experts in the
industry so this is your chance to
connect with somebody who is present in
the industry as some inside knowledge
about what goes on so what questions you
all have like I said feel free to type
in the chat box or unmute yourself right
now
any questions at all I know some people
are itching their questions this is your
chance I'm only here to observe okay
poppy observing right okay so while we
wait Vienna what are some questions that
you think they should be asking I think
a lot of students think a lot about what
is sort of the proper order of nano
degree programs that should be taking
and what requisites do they need to have
before they go into a specific nano
degree program and to the past that I
generally layout is a little more salt
driving car centric since that is my
area of expertise but I would say for
someone who's coming in with absolutely
no background in programming or software
engineering at all gives you a nice
foundation that you can build on to go
into something like intro to
self-driving cars which you can take and
do fine and if you have minimal
programming background and from then on
you can go into self-driving cars or
robotics or one of the other more
advanced ones okay so I see we have a
question in Silicon Valley what are the
chances of engineer outside of Silicon
Valley oh this is a great question I'm
so glad you asked this so it does seem
like a lot of the jobs are in Silicon
Valley and I know that can be a little
daunting but that is the case right a
lot of jobs are still concentrated at
least in the u.s. in some of the more
urban coastal areas but for example
Boston as several that I've seen New
York out there that I've seen voyage the
company that I mentioned earlier they're
operating in Florida that's or the
retirement community they work in is
located so we definitely are starting to
see the spread and there's a lot going
on international
as well so for example Udacity has a
free course on self-driving cars that we
did in partnership with I do based in
China so there's a lot going on there as
well and I think that one of the biggest
things this industry needs is to spread
beyond those urban coastal regions so I
think it would be really great to see
more of that and a lot of these
companies as well some where all of the
work can be done remotely depending on
the position and the companies that may
be an option as well if you're not
necessarily located right where the
company is but you're doing a job that
can be done from anywhere awesome great
question Henry anybody else have
additional questions we maybe have time
for maybe one or two more but like I
said feel free to type it in the chat or
feel free to unmute yourself ask yeah
great question Henry okay so we have a
couple to collect your own data verify
what that means iris
yeah could you be a little bit more
specific with your question and we'll
answer the next question what about the
labs opportunities or jobs other than
those in the industry okay so if you're
looking for something that's maybe
related but not necessarily like going
to work for lyft something obviously I'm
a little biased but something like
education could be a good opportunity
for that as well where even if you're
not the one building they assault
driving car yourself you can still have
those tools on that knowledge and use
that to educate other people about that
so I think that's a really good option
as well if you maybe don't want to be
right in the weeds with it but still
want to kind of have a foot in that
industry it's still a very new industry
right and so yeah it's a lot still being
figured out yeah it's only going to
continue to grow grow sure there's gonna
be a large kind of implementation with
businesses as well as you know consumers
so I think that there's absolutely a ton
of opportunity so this is something that
you're pursuing
and you maybe you can touch on this to
Vienna but I have conversations with
people a lot of people in tech feel like
they need to rush at like the speed of
technology and someday find them that
honestly any of the nano degree programs
that Udacity offers are extremely high
demand skills and are in my opinion only
going to continue to grow so maybe you
can chat about this kind of like people
feel the need to like become experts in
this like as soon as possible yeah I
think that's a really good point that
this industry is growing fast and while
it may be changing a lot it's not going
away anytime soon so if it takes you a
little more time to develop a skill set
that you feel really confident in that's
perfectly fine you should go for that
and try to present yourself as the best
candidate you can be rather than trying
to rush into something just for the sake
of getting there fast awesome I
definitely agree with that okay so we
can take maybe one more question IRA you
can specify your question or if somebody
has a new question or something this is
gonna be the last one we take before we
wrap up okay so she missed the beginning
from the last self-driving car webinar
she attended it seems like seem the
bottleneck is the input data shortage is
this also your case still not a hundred
percent sure what you're asking but I'll
take a guess if you're asking about
self-driving cars needing to have a lot
of data in order to operate most
effectively that is definitely true and
that is something that is being worked
on right now so I I live in Palo Alto so
I see the way Moe vehicles out on the
roads every single day and they were
just driving around continuing to
collect data so that is definitely
something that we're still working on
and the more data the better in cases
like this awesome so thank you
Vienna for sharing your insight thank
you all everyone for attending and
asking great questions if you missed any
of this we're going to have it
ordered and uploaded to the YouTube page
so feel free to re-watch back if you
missed anything or or want to kind of
hear this again but thanks again of to
Vienna thank you to the viewers and
thank you all who may be rewatching this
yeah I hope you all have a great rest of
your day thanks Tina
yeah thanks for having me breath right
bye